hf herzlich willkommen zu meinem
heutigen video leute ich sitze jetzt
zusammen mit robin zeigt sein name ist
in vilsheim einnahmen des events für
krankhafte mann namens max ich habe
heute was für euch am start bieten wir
für uns und ich war einkaufen und eine
tasse mal anschaut wir haben buchstaben
brot und einmal buchstaben nudeln also
da sozusagen die viel kleinere variante
was machen wir denn eigentlich hat das
überhaupt nichts mit dem anderen zu tun
ich meine dass man auch buchstaben aber
letztendlich sind das komplett 2 1 1 0
des anderen cakes max also ich wär halt
vielleicht angebracht der stelle wenn du
heute vormittag informiert ja hier heute
für euch die sachen testen und essen
weil ich will mir sicher dass noch
keiner
schade also wie man folgendes wir nehmen
diese buchstaben und legen daraus einen
youtuber nahm das heißt wir erwarten wir
nehmen nicht warten sondern wir erfüllen
youtuber mit unserer zunge schmecken
köstlich schmeckt eigentlich schmeckt
sagen die partie kommentierte dass
daraus wirklich ist lässt den vortritt
weitergeht das hat auch das heißt ich
glaube jetzt ist oder ich glaube sehr
pflegend du darfst sie aussuchen fertig
will essen okay das heißt ich such dir
was raus als ich schoss der bescheiden
hast du mit extra mitgebracht ja ich
habe keine ahnung ob wir hatten mal im
tank obdachlose nkufo ich weiß es nicht
diesmal früh die waffen es ist schön ist
dass ich sturm ist deshalb mache ich
kann absolut gar nicht sehen was ich
sehe nicht das alter hallo ich geb dir
was ich sehe leider sebastian hat in
berlin des computerbild gehetzt
die such mal ein youtuber nahm raus ich
mach kein allzu lang das mich zu schwer
wird aber lustig wird halo dich zeit ich
lege mir mal auf die hand hier damit ihr
es euch in der kamera anschauen
gewaschen sind dass viele leute ist das
erste wort und ich gebe dir jetzt den
ersten buchstaben nicht mehr blicken wir
auf die zunge
da ist erst buchstabe du darfst du raten
so eigenartig hast du irgendwie idee ist
es schwer ja das habe auch glaubten
besonders schwerer buchstabe er ja erst
richtig
du sagst der erste buchstabe ist eine er
dann kriegst jetzt im nächsten game da
ist der nächste buchstabe b
das ist schwer das ding ist dem kann man
halt auch anders auslegen
dort musst du dich jetzt festlegen
deshalb war ich habe noch eine von der
sorte
ich wollte einfach sagen der nächste
buchstabe kommt so batterie bis ich bin
heiß und hungrig bist der nächste leute
habt ihr so was schon mal irgendwo
gesehen das ist meine sache machen will
ok wieso es hat uns etwas einfällt nie
so überlegt hier nochmal ich gebe dir
noch eine chance ansonsten kannst du
auch noch den letzten buchstaben nehmen
wir an den letzten ob er konnte
august alter so läuft ihr erinnert euch
vielleicht warum regel dieses ding nicht
mehr auf den augen haben dass das hier
hat man zeit konnte yahoo die kammer war
voll wie hat es aber richtig erraten
das war wie der name der zweite versuch
von max leider nicht mit ort gewesen war
kelly
da muss ich machen wirklich krank helfen
ja das war's noch bis das wieder was
machen wir jetzt machen wir nochmal der
mache ist normal für dich aber okay du
hast jetzt nicht die möglichkeit damit
groß wie kleine maus entführer auch
gerne kaputtlachen
das ist wichtiger diesmal hätte ich ihr
nicht okay du bist
lecker hopp ich lasse mich auch die oft
das wort geredet ich habe trotzdem hat
er einfach experte kotzt jetzt geht
diese scheiße buchstaben nur einmal was
macht man da darf ich einen
zusammenbasteln ich mir sicher bin dass
der koppel vorschreiben ja richtig
ich gebe ihnen einen buchstaben einfach
einmal okay du sagst das sagt auch
dennoch macht es einfach doppelt also
hier
ich glaube nicht dass du kannst ja es
ist also durch das doppelte dinge
könntest du schöner garten in meinem
haus hast aber sonst ist wirklich schwer
okay dann hier setzt hier wie viele
buchstaben mit dem doppelten 5 war okay
okay gegeben unser textur der fenstertag
drauf beißt und durchschnittsverdiener
ist was fühlst du magst kannst
vielleicht im unterhalten bruder ja das
ist es
ok ok und bert nordberg du hast du hast
eine lockende mitte gespürt hat mit
zunge reingelegt 600 der ist crazy
schwer wobei es geht es geht es geht es
geht ich hätte gedacht hast du bei den p
größte probleme hast du papa ist richtig
er hat alles auf eine schnelle runde
will deine augen internat kommt die
ultimative nudeln halt sogar richtig
reingekommen sind schon heftig was mich
sehr wieder nichts hallo
ja ich bin hier ich höre ich nehme
extrem kurzen buchstaben mit platz vier
ist erste wahl sein
ok ja ja ja ja die batch den nächsten
dass er nächste saison kommt ich jetzt
einfach mal nicht okay doch das ist
richtig die maschine hat erst richtig
schnell
ich glaube jetzt kannst du eigentlich
mit viel falsch machen hier ist der
letzte coc ja ich dachte also drei
buchstaben irgendwas nicht schlecht gut
gemacht hat es an talent für dual nun
macht ich habe offen sachen dem motto
schmeck die wassermassen reißen
die leute werden sich bestimmt verändern
wenn die abkürzung raus was hast du das
ganze haus okay okay also ich lege meine
hand
ich sehe dass hier der glaube kann sie
können beginnen heute die nummer eins
khh du musst es selber sagen ich konnte
dir nicht abnehmen das denken ich bin
kein schuss ok stark stark startete mit
dem ok wir hoffen nächstes auswahl nun
die verpackung tut mir leid wirklich das
was du niemals das wird man niemals
herausfinden
ja ich glaube ja noch nach japan
verbinden die augen gerüstet als erstes
dran denke das wird damit unmöglich zu
machen könnte richtig übertreiben und
die dinger den mund geben ohne ordnung
vor dass wir noch ein anagramm daraus zu
machen ist das schon wirklich allein
weckt ihren haufen wörter gelegt und
sage welche youtuber ist das oder sind
sogar zahlen der youtube star adams
meint formaten jetzt auch passwörter was
sagen uns nichts was du alles gute so
schön ich fotografiere das kurz auch ein
tisch fachleute und blendet euch ein
da ist es leute ihr seid jetzt
eingeblendet hier hast du noch mal ein
training ich gebe es jetzt einfach mal
die hand nimmt keine chance
ja richtig es richtig ist richtig sehr
gut regiert an talent für leute hier ist
ja nicht so gut aber auch meine hand
mittel überlegt das ist ja
ok hab glaub schon ne na.de alter du
willst du nicht sein müsste weiter oben
denn er könnte ja fast abgebrochen hatte
da muss ich kann nur sagen ist ja eher
oder kuh immer so was okay ich geb dir
den nächsten und den allerletzten hätte
ist ja dass ich all das wieder dreht
aber wirklich du musst dich so krank
konzentrieren du musst so kann
konzentrieren wenn das verreisen das so
gut kann ich dir mal so stimmt zwischen
szenario hunger weißt du wenn ich jetzt
nicht drauf komme dann bist du der könig
der buchstaben aber so schnell wie du
das hier muss wirklich sagen ich glaube
du bist doch so der krieg ist erstmals
das passende finden mir fehlt noch ein
da muss ich schon sagen du dass du es
magst du bist noch jeden fall geben
würde ich als ok das wirklich jetzt also
erstmal kombinieren youtube sehr gut
deshalb ist es ist nichts geliefert dtm
fehlte diese einfachen start auch da ist
ja okay gut der ja okay du musst dich
wirklich hart konzentrieren okay ich
denke ich fand ja also das habe ich
meine vorderleute bei einem ist es
kritisch aber auch ich wirklich keinen
besseren gefunden beginnen wir mit dem
ersten max er liegt wirklich ja okay das
wäre so eine richtige stefan raab oder
oder es wirklich so
was taugen das jetzt online ist
zerbrochen ich gebe dir davon über
nebenbei oder frau würde eher sagen aber
etwas mehr mittel aber ja nicht dass die
kraft der ist halt wirklich mit dieser
pro jahr
deshalb habe ich noch einen zweiten
davon in bochum
da kommen ja nicht wie wir sagen den
letzten beiden okay
bisher ist irgendwie so teilt teil oder
teile wieder besonderen rolle
nein er kann ja das können was für eine
rolle proben redest du ich geb dir noch
eine frage ja also ich würde sagen der
ist wirklich sie macht mir der ist echt
ok kombinieren
tvtv es ist der tv am ende alles okay
ist
ich muss sagen ich passe ich glaub ich
gebe den sieg an sich aber laut kommen
nicht wäre gewesen
turin team schau dir das nicht nur noch
sagen das was wirklich dürftig ist amber
wirklichkeit nicht weiter zu stören
kritische schau mal was ja das war ein
abgewogenes wäre ja es ging nicht anders
ich konnte nichts anderes machen
man konnte es gibt kein entweder es gibt
kein ende das gibt es nicht nur so
komische bröseln remixer kein endinger
das nennen was ist denn das ist auch ein
abriss wegen dessen eltern auf ihr euch
das ist doch hier ja okay ich hab es
nicht gefunden
ich meine ich freue mich hier besuchen
dann würd ich sagen bedanke ich mich für
heute sagen ich würde zum schaden
entstand
neben der punkt geht schon an sich
gebracht hat in den böden gehalten
hättest du nicht gehört aber ich nehme
die kekse alte welt gerne ja gut dann
frage ich mich fürs zuschauen
ich glaube es war echt coole video der
wahrscheinlich so noch nicht gesehen wir
sehen uns man nicht mal wieder wenn es
wieder heißt
[Musik]